[Música]
eu sou um glaciologista um cientista que
estuda o gelo ea neve nos 10% desse
planeta está coberto ainda com essa
massa enorme de helenas ao longo dos
últimos 30 anos a comunidade científica
the glass teologia e eu evidentemente
observemos rápidas mudanças no sistema
climático do planeta terra
mais importante nós já vemos as
conseqüências desse o por exemplo
aumento da temperatura atmosférica a
mudança na circulação a atmosférica e
oceânica aumento de eventos extremos que
levam por exemplo há o derretimento de
parte da massa de gelo do planeta apesar
de apenas 2% do gelo do planeta estar no
momento derretendo isto já implica até
2100 num aumento de cerca de 70 cêntimos
até mesmo um metro no nível médio dos
mares
esse é um dos estudos que nós fazemos
usando os satélites mais avançados do
mundo o mesmo monitoramento e louco
quando nós vamos à antártica aos andes
altis mas não todas as outras montanhas
ou mesmo um ártico
mas mais importante ainda eu estou
envolvido na técnica que nós temos
melhor para a reconstrução das mudanças
da química da atmosfera e do clima ao
longo de milhares e milhares de anos na
verdade nós já atingimos 800 mil anos no
passado e isso no nosso jargão como nós
chamamos são testemunhas de gelo que são
perfurados obtidos nos grandes mantos de
gelo da antártica e da groenlândia só um
exemplo na antártica o gelo que chega
quase cinco quilômetros de espessura
com isso nós retiramos esse material que
são cilindros e levamos para
laboratórios
isso inclusive permitiu que eu fosse
primeiro brasileiro através da tarde que
chegar até o pólo sul geográfico opa
porque parece que existe agora ter
planetas que dizem que esse lugar não
existe e que portanto eu sou isso aqui
na verdade meu deus estamos voltando à
idade média
mas o importante nisso tudo é que esses
estudos têm permitido um claro o cenário
das mudanças do clima
um exemplo o aumento da temperatura
atmosférica a que o o jargão que a
imprensa usa de aquecimento global foi
de quase 1 grau centígrado nos últimos
cento e setenta anos como você pode ver
neste gráfico
mas mais importante nós temos por
exemplo nesse outro gráfico como foi a
variação do clima e do caso da
temperatura média global nos últimos 2
mil anos
nossos colegas já conseguiram atingir
800 mil anos de variações do clima
claramente que nós tivemos um período
frio que chegou ao auge no século 17 e
18 depois de espalhar esse aumento da
temperatura o que dá indicação que é
algo novo mas ainda esses mesmos estudos
na tática na groelândia conseguido
detectar avaliação do gás estufa co2 dos
últimos 800 mil anos e eu estou
mostrando aqui para os últimos mil anos
fica claro o impacto da revolução gracia
da revolução industrial e principalmente
nós aquele pontinho vermelho que marca
onde é que chegamos agora um aumento
exponencial foi de controle da
concentração deste que é o principal gás
estufa
a situação se tornou tão clara e tão
grave que em 2015 o santo padre
francisco emitiu a encíclica la galaxy e
é importante que ele ouviu a comunidade
científica e principalmente academia de
ciências do vaticano
formado por católicos fervorosos e
cientistas mais uma vez mostrando que
não há em compatibilidade entre ciência
e religião mas ao longo dos últimos anos
eu tenho observado infelizmente um
processo de negação um processo de
negação não só da questão das mudanças
do clima mais da ciência como um todo
nós já estamos vendo inclusive algumas
das coisas
seqüências nas últimas semanas do
aumento descontrolado do sampa pelas
campanhas educacionais de negação das
vacinas mas especificamente na questão
das mudanças do do clima eu comecei a me
perguntar o que está ali atrás disso
quais são os interesses que pode está
negando essa função
evidentemente nós temos a tendência
primeiro talvez até de proteção de
pensar em teorias de conspiração mas
vamos lá primeiro vamos esclarecer uma
confusão conceitual que existe na língua
portuguesa que é a questão de clima e
tempo clima o melhor tempo é a condição
da atmosfera agora em um certo momento
em um setor local e por isso eu posso
falar aqui hoje o tempo em porto alegre
o tempo meteorológico é um dia quente
com sol com vento muito fraco e que não
vai chover mas a palavra clima tem outro
significado e é a condição média das
condições atmosféricas em anos décadas
ou mesmo séculos e milênios é interset
que na língua inglesa é muito mais fácil
diz que vai ser porque nós temos a
palavra weather ea palavra hamad
deixando bem claro que são conceitos
diferentes e isso vai criar muita
confusão
mas voltando naquela minha perspectiva
será que existe alguma conspiração e o
primeiro ponto que nós descobrimos é que
posturas ideológicas e econômicas desde
a década de 1990 existe uma campanha que
envolve o uso de técnicas publicitárias
seminais aquelas em que usadas pela
indústria do tabaco no na década de 1950
1970 para negar os efeitos maléficos na
saúde humana inclusive pelo o fumo
passivo inclusive essas companhias que
são as mais conservadoras do estados
unidos inclusive associadas à olímpiada
o
super liberalismo até um anárquico
capitalista com é a contratá-lo essas
empresas
a publicitária que tinham trabalhado no
na questão do tabaco ou seja usar
técnicas similares e negar o máximo
possível qualquer interferência do homem
nas nas mudanças do clima na melhor
hipótese até mesmo na natureza mas se
acha que é só isso só uma teoria de
conspiração ou nós podemos examinar
valores percepções de realidade e a
nossa opção de que queremos aqui nesse
planeta
e aí eu comecei a olhar outros fatores
e nós vamos ver que envolve ideologias
perspectivas econômicas mais ou menos
ortodoxas e até mesmo tocar a cia
religiosa
no caso específico das ideologias é um
interessante que permeia ainda na nossa
cultura independente se é de direita ou
de esquerda a questão de uma ideologia
de dominação da natureza pelo homem e
isso vai transparecer lá no imperialismo
vitoriano na no sistema a soviético e
finalmente no capitalismo americano
ou seja nós estamos imersos que a
natureza deve ser conquistada ainda se
nós passamos por pontos de vistas
econômicos persiste nas escolas de
economia uma desconsideração do fator
ambiental está a economia ambiental e
além do que uma valorização do presente
mais ainda o imediato
alguns economistas dizem que hoje é que
eu não me chegou ponto que só se
planejar os próximos 90 120 dias ou seja
não se considera nem a geração atual e
muito mesmo muito menos as gerações
futuras dos impactos e de custo
ambiental dessas modificações e
finalmente infelizmente nós temos
ortodoxia religiosa de algumas religiões
nas alas
mas o docsis que ainda querem
interpretar natureza com base na
interpretação literal dos livros
sagrados e isso aparece tanto do
cristianismo no islamismo do judaísmo e
outras também outras religiões
sobre essa interpretação e aí só tenho
que contar um aqui um caso que aconteceu
com o colega meu que trabalha com
mudanças do clima
lá nos estados unidos a na escala de
dois mil anos até é a 20 e 30 mil anos
ele recebeu cartas ameaçando de morte
porque veja bem você está contando uma
mentira pois a bíblia diz que o mundo só
tem quatro mil setecentos anos e não 4,5
bilhões de anos
o interessante dessa história toda que a
bíblia não diz nada disso isso foi
criado pelo bicho um bispo na século 19
essa idéia dos 4.700 anos
mas veja como se repete mas está a mesma
da atrás disso é uma ideologia religiosa
onde você percebe que é fica muito
difícil para muitas pessoas a aceitar
que a interferência do homem já é muito
grande nesse planeta limitado pequeno e
que isso tá não tem uma predeterminação
de um ente superior
mas mais recentemente nós temos tido
também o problema da mídia quando essa
questão há cerca de dez anos as mudanças
climáticas apareceu na grande imprensa
me a mídia tradicional e isso é uma
crítica também a mídia brasileira os
grandes jornais caiu no mito do
contraditório ou seja a toda o
conhecimento deve sair uma posição
contrária nós temos que dá direito a
ouvir um monstro não entendendo que a
ciência e não entendendo o que
conhecimento confundido conhecimento
opinião cabe lembrar que conhecimento eu
tenho que ter evidências e tem que ser
justificada eu tenho que ter
confiabilidade
eu tenho que além da pura opinião
achismo como muitos de nós infelizmente
fazemos cada vez mais ao reproduzir sem
crítica feita news
informações erradas informações sem
referências
então esse processo primeiro começa na
própria mídia tradicional dando muitas
vezes atenção até para farsantes bufões
charlatões que não entende por que eu
veja bem eu cheguei bater a cabeça para
fora do ar e hoje está mais fácil então
não tem aquecimento atmosférico em um
cientista estava falando que hoje se ia
mais frio mais quente
nós estamos pagando processos de décadas
então nós temos que tomar muita ciência
que nós temos conhecimento e opinião e
claro com o advento das mídias sociais
isso só piorou porque os alga os
algoritmos envolvidos na seleção e
propagação no facebook e no axa e outros
ele simplesmente pegam a questão o
número estatístico de quantos links de
quantas vezes foi compartilhado e não se
essa informação é verdadeira ou não
nós podemos ir muito mais longe
inclusive infelizmente criticar alguns
filósofos franceses que erraram no na
questão do pós-modernismo não entendendo
que assim antes de tudo é uma procura da
verdade é claro que o meio social que os
cientistas vivem é uma questão muito
mais complexa
então eu espero que tenha mostrado para
vocês que a questão das mudanças do
clima vai muito mais além do que
evidências das ciências naturais sensato
mais procura mostrar o que sabemos mudar
lá essa realidade
isso envolve antes de tudo questões
valores questões valores individuais
valores religiosos há como nós devemos e
inclusive qual são nossos valores em
relação ao outro e os valores
espirituais basicamente em toda essa
questão
nós temos que pensar o quê
somente nós queremos de nossa
experiência nesse belo e até por um
momento único planeta
[Aplausos]